best holidays
that aren't actually holidays chris you
get to go first well i i mean
i'm gonna pick this one right here to
start it off sorry i mean yeah i'm not
being subtle about this or anything yeah
420 is a pretty damn good
unofficial holiday that's not really a
holiday it's a good one you know hey
it's it's it's people having fun and
getting the munchies and doing whatever
else so for a for a holiday that's not
an official holiday there's
nothing really bad to be taken away from
this one
and everybody
chills out and has some fun and gets the
munchies okay so that that can't be all
that much of a disaster 420 is pretty
good
see i was chastised for not being subtle
enough there it's out the window it's
gone this is why we're doing the draft
all right it's a football show super
bowl sunday it's not a holiday it's not
on the calendar there's nothing that
tells me that super bowl sunday is a
holiday it clearly is a holiday it's a
day that stands out on the calendar it
is a day that overtakes your entire
experience the whole day leads up to the
game that starts somewhere between 6 25
and 6 35 eastern every year it is a
special day it's so special we're trying
to make it land on a weekend that has a
holiday on the back end of it
so when we over indulge on the day
itself we can recover on the holiday
what holiday is actually used as
recovery from the day before that's the
day so presidents day weekend let's go
we need that to happen nfl so we don't
have to feel like crap on on monday
mornings i i'm with you there you know
that was probably
that was probably going to be my next
pick i think the next one i'm going to
have to go i'm probably going to go with
week one in the nfl season just start
that off i mean that initial thursday or
sunday i don't know it doesn't get any
more exciting than that i get like
chills just thinking about it right now
i always love that time of the year i
love fall of course i love football
everything like that that just feels
like it's like the kickoff of a new year
new football school just started for the
kids all of that the leaves are changing
colors to me like that first
first sunday is uh special
i now now i'm going to pivot away from
football and i'm going to address this
literally and i think i've cracked the
code i think the ultimate holiday that
doesn't feel like a holiday is your
birthday whenever your birthday is
unless it also happens to be christmas
or new year's or some other holiday july
4. your birthday
feels like a holiday even though it
isn't
i i i'm with you i wrote that down too
i mean yeah it's a holiday for you right
screw everybody else all right you give
me gifts i don't got to give you any
what a great day this is it's all about
me me me me me so i'm with you there all
right i'm going to go something along
that that spirit uh there too
snow day i mean snow day as a kid come
on was there anything better you know up
here where i grew up in in new jersey
like they played that loud siren at like
six o'clock in the morning and if it
went off that meant you had no school i
mean if you knew it snowed the night
before i would set my alarm for like 5
58 just to make sure i could hear that
damn siren go off to know we didn't have
school nothing's better than that when
you think you got school and you don't
because of the snow
i always thought the siren was the
russians put the missiles into the air
that's what i always thought so i grew
up in the 70s back in your day
and let me tell you back in the 70s when
you're growing up anytime you hear that
siren you think it's time to go into the
desert right right it doesn't work right
which stop just start with the music
um
yeah i i and since we're playing the
music you know now you get it
instantaneously they send you text
messages when
school is closed we used to have to turn
on the radio
and you'd listen and listen until they
got to the point and of course they
dragged it out so you'd keep listening
to the radio station and eventually
they'd run through the list and that
feeling
when you're counting i know was closed
for the day right that was awesome right
i still my kid hasn't been in school
you know that would be affected by snow
day high school six years now yeah um
i still get a little excited when
there's a snow day yeah high here
where's the last year the last year has
basically been a continuous snow day
it's enough that
caused the allure of the snow day to
disappear all right last one for me and
i could have gone different directions
first night of the draft kind of feels
like a holiday day after thanksgiving
used to not be a holiday but it
basically is i i'm not doing justice to
this draft if i don't say
every friday for chris sims
that's a holiday it's a great day that's
true it is every friday let me roll
around in bed let me see let me wait
hold on let me go to pft let me see did
these idiots talk about anything
interesting why i wasn't there oh no
okay all right let's get up and
let's get up and have breakfast that's
great you're right it's an awesome day
you know i mean listen i'll tell you one
holiday that i hate that that would i
might have had more fun with that draft
i don't like valentine's day okay that's
one where i'm is that a real holiday
does that consider because i was i don't
know what that's considered but i don't
like that one that one's the worst one
to me out of all holidays i just had to
get that off my chest
i don't think it's a holiday technically
yeah right i wasn't sure is that because
you're expected to do something it's
just like
that you know a bunch of like bs and
fake and oh my gosh let's go out for a
couple's dinner half these people here
are going to be divorced in the next
year but they love each other so much
i'll just say my god
let him enjoy you valentine's day
screw you i hate that day
the
mds did the calculation with 17 regular
season games yeah there will be years
when
the super bowl does land on presidents
day weekend the way presence day weekend
works it's the third monday in february
but the only way that works
is
super bowl on valentine's day
so
so i i guess you'll get the double
whammy those years you get the super
bowl on the holiday weekend and you
don't have to worry about fulfilling any
obligations in your relationship because
you're busy i'll work
all right i'll get her uh
you know i'll get my wife a chocolate
chip cookie the shape of a football say
happy valentine's day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports